-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, we're going to get
to the news.
President Biden today attended
the White House Easter egg roll.
However, due to inflation, the
kids all had to share one egg.
[ Laughter ]
"I'm gonna need that back,
guys, too."
New York mayor Eric Adams
recently tested positive
for the coronavirus,
and it's the first
positive result he's had.
[ Laughter ]
New Jersey is set this week to
begin allowing the sale
of recreational marijuana,
so now when people drive
into Jersey, instead of,
"What's that smell?"
They'll be saying,
"Ooh, what's that smell?"
[ Laughter ]
The Florida Department of
Education announced last week
that the state has rejected over
50 math textbooks
from next school year's
curriculum due to references
to critical race theory.
What kind of word problems
do those books have?
"If Johnny has to buy 30 apples
for the Black Panther
meetings..."
[ Laughter ]
The Boston Marathon
was held today.
It's the only marathon that
starts with someone yelling,
[Boston accent] "Cops are here!"
[ Laughter ]
[Normally] A Florida man
was arrested recently
after authorities found a baby
alligator, firearms, and drugs
in his car during a traffic
stop,
so they had to cancel
the gender reveal party.
[ Laughter ]
Authorities in Spain recently
detained a fishing boat
that was carrying more than
6,000 pounds of cocaine
in a fuel tank, which was dumb,
because they could have gotten
way more for the fuel.
[ Laughter ]
The athletic apparel company
Lululemon will launch a program
this week where customers can
exchange
their gently-used clothing items
for e-gift cards.
Or, if you prefer cash,
there's always Gary.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, hey, before you go in
the store, I'll pay double.
Gently used, super used. Eh."
Gary's not picky
is what I'm saying.
And finally, a man in Florida
recently broke
a Guinness World Record by
watching the movie
"Spider-Man: No Way Home"
292 times,
and then set another
world record
by watching "Morbius" twice.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody.